[拍手]
いやすごい人をラストにしてしまったなと
いうのがね僕の意見なんですけどねあの
いきなり来てすごい格好してるなというね
皆さん思ったと思うんですけどもまああの
頭から鳩は出ませんので今日はあの僕のね
経験から出ませんよ本当にねこれ不利じゃ
ないですからね急にバッて出ませんからね
今日はね僕の経験からちょっと皆様にお
伝えできることを探してやってまいりまし
たで私あの先ほど紹介いただきましたけど
もあのカイトという名前でプロのダンサー
として今
活動しておりますでそのカツ丼内容として
はですねあのダンススタジオ等でレッスン
をしたりそれからイベントとかありますの
でイベントの方でパフォーマンスをさせて
もらったりそれからですねダンス
コンテストというのも最近増えてきてるの
でそのコンテストの方で自分が
審査員をさせていただくとかそして
稀にですねあるのがあのメディアの仕事な
んですねその例えば番組に出てくださいと
かもしくはアーティストのサポートして
くださいみたいな話も結構あったりします
そういう活動をしながら僕自身ですね
ダンスも20年以上やってるんですけども
僕自身にですね実はこだわりというか
譲れない一つがあって自分に
毎回
課題を与えてるんですねそれ何かと言い
ますと1年の中で一度は世界大会で優勝
するという
課題を僕は自分に掲げて
活動しておりますはいでまぁ僕があのやっ
ているジャンルはですねダンスなんです
けども
ポップというジャンルなんですねはいでは
ここでクエスチョンタイムね皆さんあの
ポップという知ってる方どうでしょう
あなるほどですねほとんど知らないんです
ねなるほどなこれはねあの正直言います
アウェイって言いますけども
これよくあるんですよあの世界政府とも
全てがウェイなのでねその辺はやっぱりね
このマインド強くなってますから今日は皆
様
チャンスでございます知らない方たちで
知ってる方だしこれもチャンスでござい
ますなぜか世界チャンピオンが来ました
ここに今日はねその世界チャンピオンの
ダンスをね少し見ていただくというのを
やっていこうかなと思いますで知らない方
にですね今ちょっと軽くご紹介させて
いただきますがポップというジャンルは
ストリートダンスと比べる中の一つなん
ですねでその特徴はですね体の筋肉を弾く
んですよね体の筋肉をパーンとボ
ーンドーンてこうやるわけですね
びっくりしたでしょこれがポップなんです
けどもこの
弾くねこうやって踊りますあとはねよく
あるのがこう見せ方の一つしてこう
ロボットなんですよね
これですねこれね話せるからね今日この
ままお送りしましょうかね
これでも全然できますのでね
はいこんな表現をしたりしますねすいませ
ん
すいません
皆様の気をつけてくださいあまり拍手する
と調子に乗りますからね気をつけて
ください今日40分ぐらいかかっちゃい
ますから気をつけてくださいねそれ以外に
もウェーブですね体にウェーブを流すもの
とか頭分かりやすいもの言うとあのポーと
いう方ですポーっていうかですねこれ
バックスライドっていうやつですねこう
やってスライドしてますだから僕は家に
帰る時は必ずバックスライドでお家に入っ
てますけどねはいそれはさておきねであの
僕自身ですねその掲げてやってるんです
けどもあの幸いなことにですねあのコロナ
禍の前まで13年間ですねずっと世界
タイトルを取り続けることができました
13年間びっくりしたでしょうね僕も
びっくりしてるんですよねでその13年間
ですけどもあのストリートダンスの歴史
自体が40年ぐらいなんですで40年
ぐらいの中で自分が13年間勝ち続けた
経験をもとに今日は
文化を進化させるということっていう
テーマで今日話していこうと思いますで
これかなり壮大なねあの感じのテーマに
なりますけどもあの僕も思ってますすごい
テーマを持ってきちゃったなとただここは
頑張って話していきます皆さんよろしくお
願いしますはいでですねまあ今おっしゃい
ましたね私がねあの
文化を進化させることでこの前にですね
まずちょっと注目したいのが
文化を
伝承するということこっちをちょっと注目
していこうと思いますで
伝承っていう言葉なんですけどもあの僕は
主に2種類あるかなと思ってます一つが
先輩から学んだことをそのまま
忠実に習得して次の世代に伝えるやり方で
もう一つが僕らのダンシンみたいに先輩
から
習ったものを今の時代にフィットするよう
に変化させてどんどん次の世代にパスして
いくやり方っていうのがあるのかなと思っ
てますでですねこの間の伝承することで
これが僕の中でもすごく大切なことになっ
てくるのでそれを常に意識しながらですね
僕も活動をしていますはいでですねこのま
あ
伝承することって簡単に言いますけども
まあそれはまあ教えることで出来上がって
くるんですがそこだけではなくてですね
色んな活動の中で背中を見せたりとか
いろんな形があるかなと自分でも思ってい
ますでですねまあ話をちょっと戻していき
ますとまず僕らのダンスの歴史自体が実は
ポップというジャンルはアメリカから
生まれたんですねそのアメリカで生まれた
ポップというもので踊ってる人たちがまあ
映画とかもしくはテレビ番組ですね昔の
ソウルトレインとか聞いたことあるかなと
思うんですけどもそういう番組に出演され
てその先輩たちがそれを見てうわぁこの
踊りかっこいいなちょっと真似してみよう
と言って真似している踊りを自分たちが
そのパイオニアの人たちの継承して
踊ってるのを見て僕らが今度はうわ先輩
かっこいいなこれちょっと俺もやってみ
たいなということで真似て
習得していくっていうのが僕らのスタート
になるんですねでそのダンスの練習をし
ながらそして先輩たちの踊りを参考にし
ながらそして先輩たちが刺激を受けた人
たちも見ながらこう考えていっていろんな
人に教わる機会があって習っていくとある
全員が共通する一つの動きがあることに
気づくんですねそれが僕がやってるポッ
プっていうジャンルの真髄になりますで
そのコースに伝えるその部分で大事なのが
最も大事なこの真髄を伝えることが最も
大事なものと僕の中では
捉えていますでもちろんそれがないとダメ
なんですねでですね私はあの主な活動とし
てはですねダンスのコンテストに参加して
ます
大会があるんですよ世界中でその大会に
参加してトーナメントを勝ち抜いて優勝
するっていうアスリートみたいなねことを
していますでその大会はどんな大会なのか
というとですねここに
段差1人立ちますねで向かい側にもう一人
段差が立ちますねこれで戦いなんです踊り
で今日はあの格闘家みたいな感じですで
ちょっと格闘技と違うのは真ん中にあの
審査員の人は座ってるんですねでその後ろ
にDJっていう音楽をチクチクってこう
鳴らす人がいるんですでそのDJがかけた
音で僕らは踊りをね使って競い合って
どっちがかっこよかったかどっちが
フレッシュだったかどっちが素敵だったか
どっちの方がレベルが高かったのかという
のを審査して
審査員が勝ちを決めてそれでトーナメント
を勝ち抜いて優勝するっていうのが僕の
よくやってる大会に参加する形なんですね
でこの中で
世界戦に参加するとやはり
海外の人と戦うことになるのでものすごい
大きい人もいるんですよ
ムッキムキな
昔の人だったらこれ本当に巨人って思う
だろうなっていう人がいるわけですこんな
ムキムキな人はでその人がですね音に
合わせポンポンポンってやってくるわけ
ですよでもそれだけでも迫力あるんです
けどただ僕もやっぱり日本を背負ってます
から
負けるわけにいかないでよし来いとで僕も
踊るわけですけれどもその時にこの相手の
人と同じ踊りをしてたら勝てないわけです
よ
ねぇもうちょっとだって筋肉違いますしね
食べてるものが違いますからねなので
そんな時にじゃあどうするかというと
元々あるポップの踊りに変化を加えて自分
なりな表現方法で戦うんですで僕はそれを
やってたんですねそうすると審査員の人は
何だこいつ新しいなとわかってるじゃない
かってことで僕に票を入れてくれて僕が
勝つことができるというそんななんかあの
世界で僕は戦っているんですねでこの今
変化を加えましたね僕自身が今日はその
変化を皆さんにちょっとご教授しようかな
と思うんですねただこれ教えちゃうとね僕
のトップシークレットなんですねこれそう
そう世界線勝ちにくくなっちゃうんですよ
僕
でしかもこれあの世界に配信されるんです
ねこれ自分から不利な状況に追い込んで
しまうんですね
そうするとこれ困ったなーってことで
ちょっと今悩んでたんですずっと袖でこれ
を伝えるべきかもしくは自分の勝利を取る
べきかどっちかね今みんなが来てるこの
空気をどうするべきかそれとももうこの
ままお疲れしたって帰るべきなのかでも
今日はもうしょうがないんです皆さんここ
に来てくださいましたんでそしてなぜか私
が大鳥という大役を務めておりますね私
ダンサーなのでねあの普段頭よりも動き体
使ってますからねこの話を得意じゃないん
ですけどもあの今日は皆さんにご教授し
ますんで私がどうやらもうあーもうすい
ませんすいません今ね調子のレベル2個
上がりましたありがとうございますでです
ね今日は伝えていこうとまず僕がですね
その変化を加える時に
意識してるものが3つあります3つ大きく
分けてねで1つ目は音楽の変化に対して
自分の踊りを変化させるんです
これねあの簡単に言ってますけどもねあの
音楽があってその踊りまぁ昔あの初期の
踊りというのは音的に言うとズンパーン
ずんパーって音なのでそれに合わせても
ずんバーンズンパンハイプ
必殺技どうだみたいな戦い方なんですよで
それではやっぱり勝てないなと僕は世界線
参加した時もあれなんかみんな似てるなと
思ったんですよねなんでこれはちょっと
変化させてみようかなっていうことで音楽
の中のいろんなサウンドを捉えてほらここ
にも音があるじゃないかここにも音がある
じゃないかっていう表現をプラスしながら
踊ったんですねそしたらジャッジがね
こいつちょっと他と違うなってなるわけ
ですよねそして勝っていくわけです
ねこれ口で説明してもわかりませんよね
踊っちゃいますかこれね
いいですか
[拍手]
いいですね高いですよ大丈夫ですか大丈夫
ですかいいですかじゃちょっと音の方かけ
ていただいて初期と僕がやったものの違い
を今から体験したいと思いますよろしくお
願いします音楽お願いします
はい
じゃあちょっと音小さく切りましたね
ただ僕はですねこのサウンドを聞きながら
打つんですけども
こうやって細かく
表現しながらやるわけです
ねって感じですねはいありがとうござい
ます
[拍手]
すいませんこれが世界ですありがとう
ございますねこうやってこの違いが見え
ましたよね今ねシンプルに踊るのと
ちょっと音楽の幅を取りながら踊
るっていうそういう変化をつけて踊ったん
ですそうするとやっぱり
審査に響くわけで勝てるということなん
ですねこれが音楽の変化に対してダンスを
変化させていくねそして2つ目2つ目は
ですね動きをより
複雑化させるねだいたいコーンビートで
こう静かに
なんですけどもそれをね細かく
ウェーブだったらよいしょよいしょじゃ
なくてこれたします
みたいな感じですねこの細かく表現するで
それを音楽に合わせて今の曲にもあった
ように
ちょっとお得ください
出せます
ありがとうございます
無くなっちゃいましたね今ねなくなったら
ここが歌うこのままゆっくり行きますで
このビートのね
こう音を引きながらこの横に
滑って止めてくださいこれずっと踊ること
になっちゃうんでねまあそれ僕好きなんで
いいんですけどこういう風にね音の表現を
とらえてですね動きを複雑にしていくこう
いう変化をかけて踊ったわけですそうする
と見てる人がすると何これ新しいすごい
じゃないかっていうことでフレッシュだと
いうことで勝てるわけですねそして最後の
3つ目これは
神髄になるんですねこのポップダンスを
神髄ですこれを忘れちゃいけないんですね
これを外さないように踊るとしっかり
ポッポッーンの
醍醐味ですがこれがこれがないとジャッジ
からするとちょっとポップじゃないよね
それみたいなそうする評価されずに負けて
しまうことがあるのでそのポップの真髄は
絶対外さないように
踊るねこれは絶対守って踊ることが
何よりも大事なんですねで僕が下の世代に
こうすべきものはここです真髄は絶対忘れ
ないようにこれを伝えないとポップじゃ
なくなってしまうんですねこれが僕のあの
伝え方のすごく大事な部分大切にしてる
部分そして変化をかけた時に必ず忘れては
いけないものとして僕はやっていますそう
すると文化も守られるわけですねポップっ
ていうジャンルのねあのフリースタイルで
もいろんなことやっちゃうともったいない
のでそうやって真髄を守りながらやって
いくはいでこれをですねあの若者に伝えて
今度は若者が自分なりにアレンジをして
変化させてどんどん継承されていく
受け継がれていくっていうことですねで
ですねまあこんな
活動を僕しながらやってるんですけどもだ
からその
文化の中でダンスバトルという中で小さな
変化を生んでですねその変化がどんどん
こう積み上げられていって後ろを見たら
13年経った後に踊りの形が変わっていて
進化させてるということになるんですね
変化ですね変化させることっていうのを
常に僕は意識しながら
差別化を作ってジャッジの人はわかり
やすいようにして勝ち抜いてきたこの13
年ということなんですでこのですねあの
大事なあの伝えることっていう部分で僕今
ですねその下の世代ね若い世代の育成にも
力を入れてましてでその子たちに言うのは
このまあ大事な真髄を忘れないことは
もちろんなんですけど学ぶだけではなくて
自分から
作り上げる人になってくれと言い方を
変えると自分から変化させてどんどんいい
ものにしていくようにやってくれという
ことを常に伝えてます
そしてですねこれが逆に皆さんで言うと
普段皆さんの日常の中で
文化に
触れるタイミングでどうやって皆さんが
関わっているかということですねその
関わり方どんなふうに関わっていますかと
ねその中で意識的に自分から変化させて
進化させようと思いながらやってること
ありますかということですねこれはあの
かなり大げさな風に聞こえますよね変化さ
せて進化させるんだみたいな文化を進化さ
せ合うんだって思うんですけどもこれはね
あの小さな変化でいいんですそれが
いろんな人がやることでそれが集まって
大きな変化に変わってそれが進化として
いずれ後に
認識されるっていうのが僕の
意見なんですなのでですね皆さんもこの
生活している中でぜひ
ちょっとアンテナを張ってですね自分から
小さな変化を作ってみるそしたら周りも
変化し始めてそれが積もって大きな変化に
なってそれが進化につながるとそういう風
に僕はダンスの中で見つけたことでござい
ますなので今日は僕が言いたかったのは
これですねこれが
文化を進化させるということになります
ぜひ皆さんの日常でもトライしてみていい
未来を作るようにしてみてください以上に
なりますありがとうございました
[拍手]